Let's look at a very simple piece of code that implements this planning algorithm.
We have a grid here as before with 0s and 1s. You're familiar with it.
The start location on the top left, the goal location on the bottom right.
We can set up arbitrary obstacles like a wall over here and a wall over here
that forces the robot into kind of an S-curve around the corner.
If I run this code with this table, what I get is a table that looks like this.
This for each of the states that is a non-wall state.
It tells me what's the optimal thing to do.
So over here it says go south. Here is says go right. Here is says go up.
Here is says go right again and go south.
Realize that even states I'm not likely to every reach,
like the one over here and the on over here, have an optimal policy
and action associated, because there is really no start state.
There is just a goal state over here.
The specification of the initial state has no bearing on this result.
How can we compute this efficiently?
Let me make a simple example of a world like this with an obstacle over here.
Say our goal state is the one in the corner over here.
Rather than telling you how to compute the optimal policy,
which assigns an action to each of these cells,
let me instead teach you about "value."
A "value function" associates to each grid cell the length of the shortest path to the goal.
For the goal, obviously, it is 0.
For each adjacent cell to the goal, it's obviously 1.
For the guys over here, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, and 7.
This is recursively calculated by taking the optimal neighbor x-prime, y-prime,
considering its value, and by adding the costs it takes to get there,
which in our example will be plus 1.
By applying this update equation recursively,
we can attain this value function over here.
Once we have this value function, we find that the optimal control action
is obtained by minimizing the value, which is a hill-climbing type of action.
Let me give you a quiz.
In this world here with the goal location over here,
I'd like to understand what is the value of the cell in the bottom right.